[Music]
the freezing weather slamming much of
the country is more than just
uncomfortable but also poses serious
health risks the frigid temperatures can
lead to hypothermia hypothermia
compromise lung function causing
breathing problems and trigger confusion
and other neurological effects are dr.
taryn or will is here with other ways
the icy weather can impact your body and
how to protect yourself Tara good
morning Ken morning we had a funny
moment at the top of the show with
DeMarco Morgan saying it's cold out here
for our brother but it's cold everybody
I know Nikki Batista this morning why do
they keep sending us out in the cold
pretty shots but what's the biggest
health concern from where you said I
think the doctor had on well the biggest
thing to be aware of is the risk of
hypothermia yeah so if your body core
temperature falls below 35 degrees
Celsius that's when you're at risk we
have a set temperature that we like to
keep which is about 37 degrees Celsius
and it's really a balance between our
heat production through metabolism and
what we're losing heat wise from our
skin and from our breathing and so we
try to make heat so we shiver to
generate heat our blood vessels
peripherally in our arms the legs will
constrict to keep the blood closer to
our core heart kidney lungs the vital
organs our adrenal glands our thyroids
will all sort of push out hormones but
when this system fails then you're at
risk for hypothermia but does it take a
long time for a hypothermia to set in it
depends how cold it is or what your
underlying health conditions are so
elderly and infants are more vulnerable
and you have to be aware of the symptoms
because they say the cold makes you dumb
it really can affect your mental
thinking can make you sluggish it can
affect your judgment your coordination
so you may not realize that you're that
cold we reported this morning about a
gentleman who had a heart attack while
out shoveling the snow and it happens
every year every year we talk about the
increase in heart attacks and heart
related deaths in the winter there are a
lot of factors that play into this we
know that the blood pressure goes up in
the winter cholesterol levels can go up
the blood can be more prone to clotting
and as I mentioned before the blood
vessels constrict both peripherally and
also they can constrict when they supply
the actual coronary arteries can
constrict so you have a lack of supply
and an increase in demand so what what
age should you not be out there
shoveling snow so they say that if you
have underlying heart disease or risk
factors for heart disease if you're over
55 but the problem with heart heart
disease is a lot of people don't know
they have heart disease you may
coronary artery disease and blockages
and be unaware you go out you just start
shoveling snow and that could be an
issue so they suggest warming up taking
frequent breaks using a small shovel
pushing the snow instead of lifting due
to mouths don't drink alcohol or eat a
heavy meal before you go out and don't
go out first thing in the morning
because we know the first thing in the
morning is when you're more likely to
have a heart attack that's kind of the
time we see that circadian rhythm can
yeah so protecting our heart is very
important obviously but what about
protecting our largest organ which is
our skin right so frostbite is really
the risk that comes when the tissues
begin to freeze and you lose feeling in
color and this skin the chin the tissues
affected and this can affect the nose
the chin the ears the fingers or the
toes and so you want to keep those cover
they suggest mittens instead of gloves
those will work better and if you start
to notice that you're having numbness or
tingling or burning you want to seek
help for that immediately you want to
warm up those tissues either in warm
water or put them even in your armpit
they say the kind of use body heat to
warm up your digits your fingers under
underneath your arm yeah yeah but don't
put it near a radiator or stove because
if you're numb you're not gonna know how
what the temperature is you could burn
yourself so any very good information
Tara thank you so my warm yeah